reste maintenant à savoir quelle sera la
politique que mènera le dauphin de boris
eltsine devenu président par intérim
depuis ce matin nul ne sait à quoi
pourra ressembler son action à long
terme
portrait du nouvel homme fort qui se
présentera aux élections anticipées en
mars prochain
bernard lebrun son héritier c'est par ce
mot que boris eltsine présente l'été
dernier son nouveau premier ministre
vingt-deux années les séparent mais ce
n'est pas ce qui semble plus gêné
vladimir poutine homme de l'ombre il
n'aime guère les projecteurs c'est
étrange séance de judo il ne l'a
tournera que pour servir sa popularité
à 47 ans cette ceinture noire ancien
officier de renseignement d'allemagne
est alors parfaitement inconnu marié
père de deux enfants obscur
administrateur de saint pétersbourg
vladimir poutine devient patron du fsb
l'ex kgb
comment est-il arrivé là tout le monde
ignore ce faucon de la guerre en
tchétchénie a su s'imposer en cinq mois
homme à poigne parfois même grossier il
promet après les attentats de moscou je
cite de buter les terroristes jusque
dans les chiottes
il fait de la seconde guerre tchétchène
sa rampe de lancement politique mais il
pourrait en payer le dramatique kuimet
le 19 décembre derniers jours des
législatives un sondage donnait vladimir
poutine victorieux au premier tour des
présidentielles
et cette fois caméras et photographes
sont là le petit dauphin par la taille
au d'un mètre soixante cinq seulement
est devenu le grand éric
désormais président par intérim au
pouvoir considérable sans faux pas il
pourrait bénéficier de la prime aux
sortants donc